aviv latrèche merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation alors amazon 1 c'est
donc une mise en conformité sur trois
des cinq sites sur lesquels le groupe
avait fait l'objet de mises en demeure
des inspections du travail
est ce que vous êtes satisfait satisfait
oui
dans un premier temps on aurait voulu
que ce soit fait plus rapidement mais
bon là l'effet de le fêter que les
problèmes sont arrivés en tout le monde
at et plaide pour que ce soit
l'entreprise ou pâques amazon toutes les
entreprises en parle d'une pandémie
mondiale donc une épidémie qui touche
tout le monde est un moment donné mais
il fallait prendre ses responsabilités
effectivement pas faire les choses
correctement
alors en quoi les salariés 1 était en
danger sur les sites d'amazon justement
au tout début
[Musique]
il n'y avait pas il n'y avait pas tout
comment dire et pas le matériel adéquat
sion avait pas les gels et pas les
masques y avait pas la distanciation la
la distance sociale
la sq a fait amazon c'est qu'au début ça
on va dire que ça a été pris à la légère
je pense comme beaucoup beaucoup de gens
ou ou qu'on donne beaucoup beaucoup
d'entreprises mais c'est à un moment
donné il fallait prendre les choses rap
faire les choses rapidement est là ce
qu'on voit c'est qu'il ya du matin et
des gels hydroalcooliques il ya une
prise de température il ya une distance
distance sociale de deux mètres alors
que le cousin gouvernement préconise un
m c'est là qu'on voit ou effectivement
on devrait faire amazon en rendu
vraiment le cas je répète encore la
chose vendue à réagir aux lieux au plus
vite et que dès qu'ils aient eu des
cadets que yeux c'était par rapport à
l'épidémie il fallait réagir tout de
suite je pense
est-ce que ces salariés qui se sentait
en danger avec la possibilité de ne pas
venir travailler d'utiliser leur droit
de retrait par exemple je sais qui
encore un deux sites un qui doivent
encore être être
visitée par l'inspection du travail oui
comme commandement le nôtre oui alors
qu'on commence que les salariés vivent
cette situation justement alors pour la
plupart tout début surtout par rapport à
la peur par d'être contaminés il y avait
un il y avait un droit de retrait qui
est toujours en cours d'ailleurs mais
bon l'entreprise de ma ne voyez pas pour
à elle pour c'est que ben non mais
c'était pas nécessaire de faire un droit
de retrait
tout tout avait été mis en place pour
que ça se passe bien là je vais parler
au niveau de la cfdt
l'ama maintenant il ya un autre les
salariés sur me endroit de rêve et donc
du coup le droit de retrait a été mis de
côté mais c'est le droit de retrait
c'est dans le code du travail en y a le
droit
c'est ça a été mis
c'est amazon pour eux pour elle pense
que ce droit de retrait n'est pas
légitime mais non c'est tout à fait
légitime ont dès le début on s'est pas
senti en sécurité et je parle pour
l'ensemble des salariés pour toutes ces
personnes qui travaillent dans
l'entreprise pour conclure en un mois ce
qui a toujours autant de travail pour
les salariés malgré la pandémie
alors il ya toujours autant de travail
après les effectifs va ça tourne pas
comme d'habitude s'attendent un peu au
ralenti mais on va dire que il faut
[Musique]
raison garder c'est pas l'important pour
maintenant ou pour les clients eux mêmes
pour les salariés
ces deux d'envoyer des choses qui sont
importantes les choses qui sont
importantes et les des choses de
première nécessité ce soit des masques
ou des solutions hydro-alcooliques de
l'hygiène amazon au fait aussi fait un
peu d'alimentaire c'est ça l'important
est pas comment on avait dit
aux dés le départ de paula et des choses
qui sont pas utiles merci voilà merci
beaucoup habib latrèche c'est d'avoir
accepté notre invitation je rappelle que
vous êtes salarié amazon et militants
cfdt